sieger konnte mein name ist luca und wir
spielen heute gott simulator auf dem bau
oder des helikopters ist genau so
aufgebaut wie das archiv mit
es ist halt einfach ein spiel wirklich
will wir sind eine ziege und können die
ganz normal rumlaufen wie kommen wir
machen sie mal was vernünftiges also wir
können hier auf den verlangen laufen
können ein bisschen zäh ausschalten ich
bin nicht gut in diesem spiel ich bin
mir nicht sicher was man hier alles
machen kann wie krieg für jeden scheißen
verpackt ist schief manson spielen
nämlich auch wo auf ich weiß nicht was
ich von dem spiel halten soll
mit dieser ziele hier werden wir noch
sehr sehr viel spaß haben freunde
guckt euch das gesicht dann auch sie ist
unsichtbar gibt sie nicht total
fasziniert aus ich glaube sie wird es
lieben mit uns zusammen sieger bekommen
wir sind natürlich nicht hier um nur
scheiße zu moment wir sind hier um nur
scheiße zu machen wir haben eine
tankstelle können wir auch du heilige
was zum tiki kann ich nicht auf dem
schein fragt mich nicht freunde
ich weiß selber nicht was die züge dort
mit dem kopf an stellt ach du das sieht
man auf jeden fall nicht gesund aus
freunde wir brauchen namen für diese
ziege schreibt mir mal alle so viele
namen wie möglich nein nein das nicht
wir haben es geschafft schreibt immer so
viele namen wie möglich in den
kommentaren und wenn ihr denkt ja der
name ist cool dann wollte den hoch was
mache ich überhaupt gerade hier oben wir
brauchen unbedingt einen namen weil ich
bock
was soll das denn was ist denn das hier
für ein scheiß ich wollte da oben
bleiben und die aussicht genießen
wir brauchen einen namen diese stieg ich
habe du bist gegen eine mülltonne regen
gelaufen
jetzt stehen verdammt noch mal wieder
auf die brauchen nahm für diese ziege
dies so knifflig ich weiß nicht ich mir
macht das mega spaß das ist ein
typisches gesetze war ich zu tun habe
ich das grad gemacht wie habe ich mich
auf die pobacken gesetzt die habe ich
das getan dass das war definitiv nicht
der knopf zu klein ist wie bist du denn
was auch mein gott wir können springen
wo mein gott das ist ja dieses spiel
fasziniert mich also wenn ihr wollt dass
ich das nochmal hochladen oder so dann
zeigt man mit einer bewertung und
schreibt wir definitiv einen namen für
diese nein nein schreibt mir definitiv
einen namen für diese scheiße bin ich
gerade über die wand gelaufen bitte was
tatsache guckt euch das an die zügig ein
parcours
ich kann so über die wand laufen ich
habe gerade eine was habe ich eine
trophäe eingesammelt oder so normale
leute denken sich okay das ist eine
rutsche die muss ich runter rutschen und
ich denk mir ich die rückwärts runter
und tor erklärte faktisch herzige wir
haben so lange darauf gewartet
[Musik]
es kann sein dass ich eventuell schon
mal spiele als buggy ist games
bezeichnet habe in videos aber dieses
spiel top das mache ich das ist keine
halfpipe was soll das ist so eine
unnütze stück scheiße was kannst du
überhaupt keine ahnung wollt ihr zweiten
tat also ich glaube die ziele und ich
sind auf jeden fall total begeisterte
freunde wollte mit mir zusammen 40
gemälde und kleiner finger
es tut mir tut mir sehr leid
jetzt kommt ein auto von der seite new
yorks ich bin nur zu besuch
okay ich habe irgendwie eine zunge ich
weiß allerdings nicht was ich mit dieser
zunge ist nicht wahr ich kann mit der
zunge denn ist nicht das was ich denke
ich kann die typen mitnehmen ich kann
den gott verdamme mitnehmen nein
es funktioniert nicht ich kann nicht
hoch klettern mit dem common ich wollte
ihm eine aussichtsplattform zeugen aber
zum glück gibt es in diesem spiel so
viel zu erleben dass wir zusammen
rutschen gehen können
wo ist er hin daher sagt irgendwie hat
das mit was ist das für ein bagdad
wollen ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
nerven mehr weiterzuspielen wenn ihr die
zweite land noch sehen wollt oder
empfehlungen habe was ich noch machen
kann die cvp könnte mir das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben dann wenn ich
eventuell noch einen zweiten teil doch
simone aufnehmen oder einen dritten oder
vierten oder